[Music]
this is a ship that could launch a
thousand others the rizzoni is the first
cargo vessel to carry ukrainian grain
through the black sea since russia
invaded on february the 24th george
has said
it was a great feeling
i felt as if we became free after being
detained for a long time
trailing a pilot ship the rizoni is a
test run bound for istanbul then lebanon
if all goes well many more will follow
alexi goncharenko a member of the
ukrainian parliament came to watch
history in the making
it's the liberation of the black sea
from putin and from russian empire he
tried and did everything he can not to
give this ship and other ships
possibility to level their support and
for almost half a year it was like this
but as you see he failed
the ship departed despite several
russian attacks in the region and on the
port of odessa itself since the u.n
brokered an agreement between ukraine
and russia for this safe passage via
istanbul
it's been a long time coming but this is
the ship everyone's been waiting for
coursing through wartime waters on its
way to feed the world
ukraine says the shipments will create
jobs and provide money to fuel the war
effort
as the first of last year's delayed crop
leaves farmers risk their lives for this
season's harvest sometimes led by
demining crews
sometimes not this harvester struck an
explosive the danger on the grain trail
continues on the black sea journey to
turkey through waters dotted with sea
mines in an active war zone
it's all managed through a joint
coordination center in turkey an
extraordinary collaboration between
representatives from the u.n ukraine and
russia we believe that it's critical to
in to ensuring global food security so
yes we need to succeed
whether this is the beginning of the
effort to avert a global food crisis
or the end depends in part on the voyage
of the rizzoni john hendren al jazeera
odessa ukraine
well that's the latest from ukraine
let's get mona from istanbul where that
ship is uh initially headed al jazeera's
cinema kosiolo is there
we are expecting that this journey is
going to be around 220
230 c miles so
the first ship left other support and we
are expecting some more ships leaving
their ports and joining with the razony
vessel somewhere in the black sea and
like a sm like a convoy of vessels they
are expected to reach the shores of
istanbul upon the north at the black sea
shores of istanbul before they enter the
bus first straight there's an encorage
area all ships all vessels always anchor
there before they they get their
paperwork done
before entering the turkish race and for
this special vessels carrying ukrainian
grains they will be inspected by a un
u.n led delegation when they anchor off
there the vessel is expected to anchor
off
on the shores of istanbul around 12 gmt
which is around 3 p.m local normally in
an ideal world in a in a sta in an
established system these kinds of
inspections take around three to four
hours but as this is the first crossing
of the ukrainian uh grains vessels this
may take longer so we don't know when
those vessels will
literally enter the bosphorus straight
but as they enter the bus first straight
and cross the mount mara sea through the
dardanelle strait these vessels are
going to sail towards the agency and
then towards down south to the
mediterranean and hopefully will carry
the corns and grains all food materials
to their first destination tripoli
lebanon